want to say something right now because
this is my podcast and I am you really
broke my heart when you lost to clay
Guido okay okay let's talk about it
let's know I you know I was on the UFC
fight pass I was on the road I go
[ __ ] Erik's fighting I put it on and
it I've never known just let me finish
it was it was it broke my heart it's
weird watching somebody different I
threw my iPad and everything really yeah
I was emotional about I think Stevie was
really upset everyone we all hold each
other afterwards what the [ __ ] happened
right well touching on that like
watching the clock into the mic man the
craziest thing about about fighting is
like when you fight yeah you're nervous
but it's a different type of nervous
energy yeah it's like I know I got to be
in there and I like I got to be on
everything like it's more it's more of a
focus like nerve yeah when you watch
people you know fight like when I watch
my teammates fight I lose my mind I'm
well I can't believe we do this for a
living who I this is [ __ ] crazy
yeah and so it touching on that like
watching people you know fight is
watching my brother fight was probably
the worst thing really I'd lose my [ __ ]
all your brother yeah you know so if
they even get hit you get mad you want
to climb the fence and you know that's
how I felt I think yeah yeah but and he
was on top of you like he doing all that
gay [ __ ] would do any damage I know I
know he didn't Eric will go into the
fight will go into the fight yeah the
fight was very it was just a strange
fight because he's such a weird guy to
fight you know when he fought Anthony
Pettis my teammate yeah he was coming
forward everybody's used to guida moving
his head like a high energy yeah he
fought way more patient with you with me
yeah didn't come forward with the whole
the whole game plan was to counter and
you know fight him you know because he
wants to come forward later let him you
know hurt himself by falling on the
sword but he never did that he was a
very patient and he wasn't like super
strong his takedowns weren't super
strong but just like he did just enough
to get me down yeah you know and the one
thing I give credits clay
he's such a veteran like when he has you
down it is hard to move like he doesn't
take risks to posture up and be damaged
but he controlled my hips so well
usually I'm good off my back I can throw
submissions up and I can move I've never
felt like that like against the fence I
would try to wall walk yeah I jump off
he would shut me down he knew exactly
what I was doing he's just a veteran
yeah you know so what I take from that
fight is you know I'm not I'm not hurt I
didn't take any damage you didn't look
good afterwards you didn't look good
after work I'm just saying because I
want you to succeed I want to I know you
do try and so that's where my thing was
coming from it's like I want Erica home
but I would be really terrible being a
spectator to my kids sporting events
yeah I an in your right like I would
much rather compete than be a spectator
to anything it's it's because you have a
set of nerves that you can't kind of
dispel like you when you're watching you
have all this built-up adrenaline that
you can't use towards movement exactly
you when you're an athlete you have this
adrenaline you're about to actually use
your body towards something but the
power is in your jaw
like when you watch somebody you love or
a training partner you want to do it for
him yeah and when you're watching from
like a third-person view it's a lot
different it's a lot different
yeah actually face to face I mean I know
I wrestled in high school I know it's
not the same but but I did tournaments
and stuff right and I used to get so
I've never been more nervous it's more
nerve-wracking than standup I couldn't
believe like trying to make a wait and
then and then actually go walking in
it's so nerve-wracking so I can only
imagine because you're at a higher level
that you can use there's so much at
stake well yeah and yet you were you
were also played with injuries and
whatnot so there's you hadn't been back
in a long time right right so there was
a lot riding on it Peter you were I mean
the biggest thing about it is in any
sports you know a lot of sports that are
like football soccer they're team sports
so if you lose the blame is kind of
dispensed yeah like you can put it on
other people in fighting when you lose
it's the [ __ ] worst
when you win it's the grace that's why
we do it there they're both you know
total extremes yeah yeah so I mean yeah
it's it's [ __ ] terrible I hate lose
you cry I did you did every loss I cried
because here pretty soon I'll part know
the best way I can put it is a Tito
Ortiz he said it [ __ ] him why he used to
say he's like when you lose the fight
it's like a loved one dying because we
trained so [ __ ] hard at that that's
why not many people do this we train so
hard and people really don't understand
how hard we train and when you lose a
fight and you dedicate three months to
dieting cutting weight training four
times you know a day watching tape
you're just your whole life is dedicated
to this one day yeah you're not doing
anything pass can imagine it's just like
that's Judgment Day that's like that's
the under days for you until the fights
actually over yeah that's the end of the
day so like when you lose a fight it's
weird because it doesn't hit you in the
cage it's when you go back and you can
you you you know the disappointment of
your corner not necessarily they're mad
at me but like they're just bummed you
lost and yeah they like you let a lot
more people down but you weren't
humiliated you were doing so good no but
I take I take pride one good rao's I did
with Amanda Nunez I mean she was picked
apart within a minute and she was out
you can tell that she trained hard for
the oh yeah yeah
I can't imagine especially the kind of
expectations on her I can't imagine what
that feels like
Jose Aldo going out for two seconds like
when you've been undefeated your whole
career crossing I mean that man cried a
lot suffering I can crushing I don't
that's why I always think about whether
or not I want my kids to be you know if
if they can get there if I do want to
encourage for them to be like
professional athlete
he has so much it becomes so ingrained
as your identity that when it's gone
it's so hard to separate yourself from
that well and that's I mean that's with
a lot of fighters that have problems
retiring that's what you see you know a
lot it like I thought Anderson Silva
when he defended his belt like eight
times he should have retired if you were
to retired because his we all do this if
you ask any fighter yeah we do it to
make money but I didn't start this to do
money when I started training UFC wasn't
big at all it was so underground like
Apple didn't really didn't know much
about it so like what my stance on it is
I do this because when I die I want my
name to be remembered it's a way of it's
my everything that we do immunity I do
stand up to do that yeah yeah but I mean
that that's why I do it so if someone's
on a rate like GSP I honestly don't
think you should come back yeah you know
I feel like if he stayed that yeah but
you give it this way it's alright it's
like when you're away from the game for
that long your name fades no matter who
you are right and so you get addicted to
the glory too and the adrenaline it's a
it's a drug Oh first right for sure
so that's what they come back they go
you know they want to be the center of
attention again they want you know if
they win they want that glory that
feeling that you said right so you can
understand like why they come I
completely understand
but if you're looking at long term you
know you got you got a you got to think
about it MMA there's so many ways to
lose so many ways to win so many ways to
lose yeah you're gonna lose doesn't
matter how good you are
you know Conor McGregor he's lost not
Johnson you actually lose let's get into
that know more than just that because
your brain is on the line it isn't is
like isn't swimming it isn't track you
could be hurt for the rest of your life
that you're doing so much more is on the
line than just losing you know
[Music]